es tiempo para la economía aquí en
France 24 para ello tenemos un viernes
más a nuestra compañera Daniela hablando
en Dani bienvenida y vamos a empezar
hablando de cifras de desempleo en
Estados Unidos claro Soy Francia Acaban
de salir Rodrigo específicamente 3,5% se
ubicó el desempleo en marzo esto baja
frente al 3,6% de febrero y quiere decir
Que muy posiblemente la Fed tenga que
seguir subiendo tasas en su próxima
reunión pues Seguiremos ampliando esta
información de última hora Dani nos
vamos ahora hasta Turquía con algo que
ya habíamos hablado en el noticiero es
ese acuerdo de granos un tema clave
dentro de la guerra en Ucrania un
acuerdo diplomático muy importante que
se ha dicho sobre este tema en esa
reunión puedes saber Rodrigo este
acuerdo que permite la salida de granos
a través de puertos ucranianos Data de
julio y vence el próximo 19 de mayo
después de una segunda prórroga de 60
días pactada justo antes de que expirara
en marzo pasado Rusia ha sido renuente a
seguirlo extendiendo porque exige que se
eliminen las barreras a sus envíos de
alimentos y fertilizantes si bien Estos
rubrosos no son sujetos a sanciones
occidentales
Moscú dice que las restricciones en las
Industrias de pagos como el sistema
Swift así como la logística y también a
los seguros son un obstáculo
extendimos ese trato una vez por 120
días y no vimos ninguna señal de que
esos problemas siquiera intentaran
resolverse y nos cansamos de llamar a
los responsables de esto y apelar a la
subconsciencia sí decidimos proponer la
prolongación del acuerdo por solo 60
días pero si se mantienen los obstáculos
para exportar fertilizantes y granos
rusos Tendremos que pensar si en
realidad Necesitamos este acuerdo bueno
Daniela llevamos ya varios meses
hablando de la importancia de este
acuerdo pero por qué es tan importante
Pues porque Rusia y Ucrania son
proveedores mundiales de trigo cebada
aceite de girasol y otros productos
alimenticios asequibles de los que
dependen los países en desarrollo este
pacto garantiza El Paso seguro de esos
granos y otros productos básicos desde
los puertos ucranianos a pesar del
bloqueo naval ruso el único verdadero
avance diplomático hasta el momento hay
que decirlo sin embargo aunque esto ha
significado un alivio La cosecha de
cereales de Ucrania en 2022 cayó
drásticamente alrededor de 53 millones
de toneladas desde un récord de 86
millones en 2021 todo esto debido a la
invasión rusa
vamos ya con la primavera en el
hemisferio norte con ello llegan estas
reuniones típicas de primavera del fondo
monetario internacional y el Banco
Mundial que van a tratar ahí pues llegan
con muy malas perspectivas como telón de
fondo de estos dos principales
prestamistas globales a su reunión de
toda la semana entrante en Washington el
fondo monetario internacional Espera que
la economía mundial crezca menos del 3%
este año y que se mantenga en torno a
ese nivel Durante los próximos cinco se
trata del pronóstico de crecimiento
mediano plazo más bajo desde 1990 y está
también muy por debajo del crecimiento
promedio de 3,8% observado en las
últimas dos décadas ya en 2022 el
crecimiento había sido del 3,4% en el
planeta pues este prestamista global
cree que los más afectados por supuesto
van a ser los países pobres que hoy
tienen más costos de endeudamiento y
debilitamiento de sus exportaciones
significa que el crecimiento per cápita
se mantendrá por debajo de las economías
emergentes
ese es un duro golpe lo que se traduce
en que es aún más difícil para estos
países alcanzar a los que están mejor
la pobreza y el hambre podrían aumentar
aún más
no es nada nuevo que muchas veces los
países más pobres son siempre los que
salen peor parados nos vamos a Reino
Unido porque parece que las autoridades
ponen la lupa sobre Amazon Pues el
regulador de competencia británico
investigará la adquisición por parte del
gigante de comercio electrónico de I
robot corp Ese es el fabricante de las
famosas aspiradoras robóticas llamadas
rumba ya la Comisión Federal de comercio
de Estados Unidos está revisando esta
compra planeada por 1700 millones de
dólares con la que Amazon pretende
expandir su conjunto de dispositivos
inteligentes para el lo que temen las
autoridades Es que este acuerdo pueda
reducir la competencia en el mercado en
este tipo de dispositivos de todas
maneras si llegara a darse esta sería
una de las grandes adquisiciones de
Amazon en los últimos años que ya
incluyen al gigante de la Alimentación
Hall Foods o los estudios de cinemg y
hasta la división de salud One Medical
bueno Dani antes de irte de rumba vamos
con la tienda del día pues la cifra del
día nos compete a nosotros dos que
vivimos en Colombia Rodrigo porque la
inflación interanual en marzo fue del
13,34 por ciento su nivel más alto desde
1999 Pese a que la tasa de interés ha
venido subiendo hasta niveles récord en
décadas los precios siguen siendo altos
jalonados principalmente por alimentos
artículos para el hogar salud y
transporte y también Pese a que las
autoridades habían dicho que ya habíamos
llegado al pico pues no Hemos llegado a
ningún pico esperemos que este sí que
sea el pico ya porque se nota en el día
a día Dani Muchas gracias por este
repaso económico
nos vemos y a nuestros espectadores les
invitamos a que sigan en Francia 24
[Música]